uh how are you doing
you know i i am alive and
breathing and i'm in hawaii directing
doing what i love
so i feel very blessed very lucky right
now stephen
i was actually gonna ask you so it's
great wait you said that when we're done
and i'm talking to you so it's free sure
uh i have a bunch of questions for you
um and uh
about the movie just some fun stuff but
i actually wanna i'm gonna start with
the hawaii thing
for what are you what are you directing
in hawaii for people that don't know
i am directing the remake of doogie
hauser doogie kami aloha
and they are um for disney plus since
20th century i believe i don't know if
they're called something new now but
um i am loving it it is
about a 16 year old hawaiian doctor and
she's brilliant and genius and the
actress peyton lee is
brilliant and genius and such a
gracious loving young star and i'm just
having the best time in my life i love
directing
love pardon me for not knowing are you
directing the pilot or is this another
episode
another episode yeah yeah no no i'm not
directing the pilot it is i'm on up
they're on episode eight
but they moved the schedule around for
me because i was on another project
aaron o'malley directs the finale and
she's a phenomenal director
but i am directing episode uh eight that
happens to be shot at the end so and i
know what it feels like to like say
goodbye to
it or like wrap up the first season and
so i'm just hoping to give them like all
the love and care and the excitement
because it is
bittersweet you know it can be very
bittersweet completely uh uh
believe me i want to jump into that but
that's another time um
so everyone i talked to during the
pandemic uh i asked a whole bunch of
first questions
they're fun it's you know you'll see and
nothing's hard-hitting i promise
um what tv series would you love to
guest star on besides the remake of
doogie howser
boys oh okay
uh that's quite good uh what movie or
movies have you seen the most
i'm not the biggest repeater i can't i
don't often repeat movies
unless they're comedies comedies i
repeat tons
um i'm trying to think of what comic you
know like
a big repetition it's not a movie now
but it's always sunny in philadelphia is
a big repetition
kim's convenience is a big repetition
the good place is a big repetition
in my household completely superstore
right i understand why um which uh which
movie
scare which movie did you see too early
in your life that really scared you
poultry guys could you look under your
bed after you saw the movie or were you
done
no under my bed closets dark places
dark spaces like if the lights are out
i'm like
you're behind me i completely got it uh
what movie
or tv show props do you own
what movie or tv show props yeah what
did you hypothetically borrow from set
i never took anything really
yeah i never took anything really no was
it
was that like were you mindful of like
not taking anything were you like scared
that you were just
people would call you like a thief or
what you know
i don't know i feel like i got
a lot from each project and i guess i
didn't
need any more i understand when didn't i
didn't know i was allowed to
or i didn't ever ask you'd be you'd be
surprised how many people i speak to
that say
you know i'll say it to you but this is
hypothetical i actually don't have this
because i don't want the production
knowing you know
that that kind of stuff right when did
you feel
during your career that you made it
enough
like that you had made it that you could
like take a month off and you would
still be able to pay your rent
oh oh well yeah i mean like i was a
i did not have anything prior to jane
the virgin so jane the virgin
was the first like real stable job
i had and so i
saved my pesos i am not a big spender at
all
i um i've i
can take time off because i have a very
like i don't buy a lot
i i understand completely um do you
remember what it was
that got you interested in the
entertainment industry was it a
performance was it a film
was it something that clicked and you're
like oh my god i want to do that
oh god it had to be so many things i
started off as a dancer i always knew i
wanted to be on stage and
i loved i loved being on stage
when i was a dancer and watching
everyone dance along with us
and be so moved by performances so i
feel like i
always loved and wanted to be an
entertainer and was always entertaining
like
family and whatnot but when i saw
america ferreira and real women have
curves that's when i said
this is i can do this because america
showed me that i like that we were seen
she she showed me it was possible you
know and like rita moreno had done that
for me
and lots of the incredible latinx uh you
know actresses out there had done that
but
america ferreira and real women that
that was a very different i was and i'm
like i think a few months younger than
her
or older i can't even remember but the
point is is we were about the same age
so it was like 16-17
when she did that movie i think she was
like 17 18.
that was when it really was like yeah
this is what i this is what i want to do
have you ever told her this information
i do i don't know if she believes me but
i meant it i really meant and she
continued to do that for me
in ugly betty and and you know sister of
the traveling pants and
she was a really big reflection for me
to say like uh i can maybe i can do this
too
you know and i think that's what's
really set me off
knowing that i wanted to do that for
others too
you know let them know that if i'm
capable they are
ten times more capable when was the last
time a director told you
we really need you to get this in one
take when i was on bold and the
beautiful
when i was on a soap opera and they
needed to get it in one take
and it was the greatest learning
experience of my life and it was right
after philly brown
before jane the virgin and it taught me
memorization like you couldn't believe i
was doing 40 50 pages a day
one take you just had to come with it
bring it hard
do your best and then you had to let it
go
and that was great training for me yeah
i can't imagine what it's like to try to
learn that much dialogue
every day it is something else and it's
like
you know it is the way you you know i do
a lot of like mind games and
you know to kind of keep my memory
active and going because that is
i guess maybe maybe my biggest you know
thing is i i can memorize really quickly
so
i'm like oh gotta keep like exercising
my brain and that like tool and
sharpening that tool you know
completely uh about to talk about awake
i swear
but i i am a huge fan whatever you want
stephen i don't care
oh no you know something let me jump
into awake because i realize that i'm
running out of time um
for people that have not seen the
trailer aren't familiar i hate asking
the generic thing but like how have you
been describing it to friends
oh uh how have i been describing it to
friends it is a sci-fi movie that now
feels a lot realer than
it did when i made it it is a um
it is a you know it is a venture into
um these faces of unknown
and it is a roller coaster of
self-discovery and resetting one's
perspective of the world and one's
life that's that's good i like that
i don't know i don't even know if that's
how i've been describing it but that's
how i'm going to do it now
one of the things uh about uh the film
and it there's it takes it's like it's
it's imagining of what if
you know a what-if disaster for the
planet uh people love these kinds of
movies i love these kinds of movies what
is it about this genre that people love
i don't know but i think
i i don't i don't know if i i say i
don't know because that was like the
first
gut reaction but if i was to like
dissect why i enjoy
these what-ifs is because i think we're
constantly
questioning the meaning of life we're
constantly wondering
the um or at least i am i'm constantly
trying to search
for answers that unfortunately
there are none for and i i think that
it helps us expand our perspective of
the world
and um i think what ifs are
important to start asking questions and
you know they they definitely help you
um
start thinking about your own your own
self and your own evolution
and you know how you shed bad habits and
how you would perform under pressure and
you know how mindful you're being so i
don't know
maybe it's because we're always all
wondering what
what is what's going on what is this
life
what it what is life what it what is
this
meat suit that i'm wearing you know like
what what
what one of the things about the movie
is um there is a car crash sequence with
water uh and i would imagine that might
have been an interesting thing to film
so what was it like filming that
sequence so awesome
i love stunts i love love
pushing my body and my physical
possibilities i love seeing what i'm
capable of i love
trying and failing and trying again and
you know that stunt we all did
including ariana including the baby girl
she did she was in that you know like
they put us almost on like do you know
those bingo machines where you go
and then they pull out a bingo thing you
know they put us in essentially that and
spun our car around and around and
um i was just so impressed by ariana and
lucious because i
i live for that kind of stuff and it was
difficult and intense and nauseating and
awesome
and so so fun me and lucious swam across
an entire lake
did we know we could do that not till
after we did it
like you know so i love seeing what i'm
capable of where i have to work harder
where i have to like
try harder and i i love pushing my body
to the limits for sure
safely safely with a sequence like that
how is it one of these things where they
are really trying to do it
in one take or is it one of these things
where like like for example how many
times did you guys have to do that
you know i'm trying to remember i think
maybe like
uh not more than 10 but upwards of six
seven times for sure and it was one take
i mean that's the cool i mean mark
really him and alan poon the
uh the dp they came up with some
really really do and as a director you
know i was extremely i was always
watching them and always seeing what
they were coming
up with shot wise but there were some
really ambitious
warners that we went for that were um
really cool because you gotta try right
you gotta you gotta go for it
and so that warner was
hard but but it's such a win it's such
an awesome win
when you go for a challenge an obstacle
that you know that difficult
and and and get something really cool
out of it
yeah the other thing is i don't think
that the general audience that is not
like a movie fanatic
i don't think they understand what that
there
isn't a cut i don't think they realize
they're watching a runner
but i do believe that they feel the
intensity rising
you know yeah yeah no 100 and i can't
i at times don't recognize it i'll have
to go back and be like wait wait they
never even cut
hold on they didn't cut let's go back
and like see that but you your body does
shift as a viewer you don't know why
and and i i also as somebody who works
in the industry sometimes
don't know why and have to like analyze
what the shot did for me
or what the cinematography did for me
that was outside of the words that was
outside because there's so many crafts
you know when it comes to this it's not
you know just the actors you're looking
at is from the set design to the
costumes to
you know to hair to makeup to you know
because i had
to you know um my body had to evolve
you know it's down to every single craft
that is working really hard at doing
that and there's at times you don't know
what
is at work but you feel something
different
you know 100 you mentioned directing and
how you're doing
googie and you've directed other tv in
the past
um are you thinking about are you
developing trying to do a feature
um and what can you tease about
something like that
uh i am 100
trying to um be in that space and i will
say there is some really cool
cool things that it's something very
cool i'm going to be able to share very
soon
got it i understand so basically i wish
i wasn't talking to you in like three
weeks when the con when you guys
announced
100 maybe let's talk in three weeks
when it's announced uh i completely get
it um and yeah
obviously like i'm very enthusiastic to
see um
your vision for a feature and
you know um and bringing your uh what
you want to do to life
um but i so i do want to ask you though
before i run out of time
uh you obviously have other stuff in the
fire other stuff you're developing
one of the things we've talked about in
the past or perry talked with you about
is carmen santiago
um like what's going on with some of
these things
um so like which ones um
i'm like you know as a producer you know
i have a production company i can label
productions and
i didn't start on this side right i
started on the
in front of the camera side so venturing
into
these producerial space has allowed me
to
really you know learn so much about the
creative process and the production
process but
i will say that we have projects in all
phases of production
so we are in pre-production right now
for a film that we are producing with
netflix
that we will start in july we are in
you know um the development process for
a really awesome interactive rom-com on
netflix we're in the developmental
process on
three television shows you know some of
them are at script level other than
like ones that outline other script
another one is like
fully going through so we're just in
like different spaces which is really
fun
to be to see to birth
to be a part of growing and and
cultivating and creating
something i didn't do before you know
something where i felt like i was
definitely in the sea
like more in a and i wouldn't say
powerless but 100
not taking control of that which i can
when it comes to art and creation and
contributing
and so now i'm more in that and that has
been a really really fun shift
so we're all over the place on all of
them
but you know very very blessed and just
like so
thankful that i get to keep doing art
that's all i want to do
the thing is a lot of people don't
realize and it's funny when i when i
interact with people on social media and
they
i don't think some people realize that
acting
you don't have the power that you have
as a producer
or a director or developing projects
yeah it's a completely different beast
and i don't think a lot of people
will not not everyone realizes that yeah
well i mean and
and rightfully so i get it because from
the outside looking in the
people you see are the actors they are
the ones that are presented to
the consumer and to the audience because
you know that's how we have positioned
this you know and what's really
beautiful about this shift is we're
really starting to understand the
importance
the gravitas of the writer and the cr
you know the show runner the creator
the director's voice or you know and and
and
we're starting to talk about it a little
bit more in spaces
that of people that where people don't
really know our
industry and so it's really cool to
start talking to people that are not in
our industry to say like
oh that writer i you know like that's
the writer of so and so and that i
really like that
and you're like yeah there are a lot of
contributing artistic
pieces to this puzzle and so you get why
the audience is like it's the actor i
mean it's either good or bad because of
the actor
or you know and and you know i think as
an actor that can you
have a lot there's a lot of pressure
there because you cannot you
you only have this much you only can
give this much and
and and rightfully so it's what you sign
on to it's what you say
i want to be a part of the this is the
puzzle piece i choose in this project
you know and so i'm i i've been able to
sin in a few different puzzle pieces
that really give me perspective of like
of the other ones
um but i completely empathize from uh
you know there's a lot of industries i i
know nothing about
and and so you know if anybody someone
wants to talk about it i
geek out over it because you know the
producer is so creative there'd be such
creative producers that really helped
craft and mold and
you know and then there's very business
oriented minds that really help make
something happen and push through so
it's very cool to like start seeing
how how important these other roles
are and how i can hopefully
bring a kindness a transparency a really
cool culture
when i'm in these other spaces to the
sets that i'm on
you know completely i'm very excited for
lost ollie because it sounds really cool
and i'm into animation and stuff like
that so
what can you tease about that project
and what what of the animation have you
seen
so i haven't seen any of the animation i
mean i saw what i did see was the vision
that peter ramsey and chan and tyndall
had
for the project so i was given you know
this is the this is the world we're
gonna live in
so there was like a rough um
rough animation for me to understand as
someone who was
interacting with this um
doll and so there were
so many different it was so so cool and
peter ramsey is
phenomenal and i'm so in love with that
man's artistry and the way he works and
his kindness and his calmness and his
like he is so graceful he is so loving
and those are the those are the sets i
love to be on that's where i definitely
work
that's the you get the best version of
me if you're if it's love and kindness
i i can i will be free i'll do whatever
you know what i'm saying like i
i think those are definitely when you
get the best out of the artist and peter
exudes that
in spades and i got to work with jake
johnson and he played my husband
but i also got to work with puppetry
like
these incredible
incredible artists that literally make
puppets look like human beings like i
just looking at this little puppet i can
just bawl i mean but then i also i mean
it was really well wait until you see it
you're gonna be like this is the cutest
little thing i've ever seen in my life
like in my life this this puppet has
light like this puppet has life behind
it like how is that even possible
um but then i also acted with silver
balls
and then i also acted with nothing
and it is a it is definitely an
emotional piece it is definitely like
what i loved about fred rogers mr rogers
is that he spoke to children about
things that
were very difficult to speak about
grief he would talk about grief and
trauma and like
in a way that i really benefited from
growing up because it was really hard to
talk about that
in our house and um and grief is
something you know when a child
experiences it
it's uh it's something that definitely
should be spoken about right i mean i
think
personally and so
you know this this is a piece that deals
with some really heavy content geared
towards speaking to children that have
gone through this and i think especially
after the
year and a half we've had where people
have unfortunately lost their parents or
grandparents and
you know and siblings and you know
friends and family members
to talk about grief um it was
really important to all of us to
to be able to like you know to to be
able to share in our piece like this
during our time
um but it was really interesting to
perform it was
it was a very different challenge for me
very different challenge i'd never done
that before
you know and talk about having to do
some heavy performance
we're going to find out if i did we're
going to find out how that came out but
um but i wouldn't trade that experience
for anything in the world not just
because peter is
the most exceptional you know human
being that i've worked with but because
i really had to push myself to some
limits
and that's kind of all i'm looking for i
mean that's what i did with awake i just
i knew that there were challenges in
there that i did not know i could be
i was capable of and i wanted to see if
i could
try even if i failed i just wanted to
try
you know and i and for lost ali that was
another beautiful challenge i mean this
gorgeous artist making that project so
it was a like it was
literally like it was a gift from the
heavens um
but i do know it was i didn't know it
was gonna it was gonna push me in ways
that
you know we're gonna see if i um what
you know
what i did i'm i'm confident in your
ability but getting back to the
beginning of this interview when i
mentioned
hypothetically borrowing things from set
see this is the kind
of item you should have borrowed well
they told me i was gonna be able to have
one
so i think i'm still gonna be able to
get an ollie doll
i just know they had to make sure they
finished and they were still working
after i left so
i'm gonna hit up peter for that ollie
doll right and by the way
you should because that's the kind of
thing you want to like frame
or do something with do something
special as like
you know and have it in your office you
know oh i do
have um but it never made it on air jane
the virgin did this like
puppet episode where like in my mind i
saw us all as puppets
and so they got real puppeteers and made
full-blown
like like two us puppets
so but it never aired because it didn't
end i guess i don't know i don't know
why jenny didn't
maybe tonally it didn't work but
whatever it was
i got that puppet and it is really
creepy and fantastic and i wish we were
home because i would pull out the puppet
it's so i do have one thing you're right
i do have one thing
i didn't i didn't steal it they didn't
give it to me it just never made it on
air
right have you have you put a photo of
that online
no not yet you should probably do that
somebody did i think justin might have
put a photo of
mine his and brett's puppet
there you go yeah that that's definitely
awesome to have
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop there and just
say thank you so much
for giving me your time and putting up
with my uh technical issues
and i do look forward to hearing about
whatever this project is that you are
directing that i'll wish i
was asking you about today um
uh i am very curious uh but you know
congrats on everything and enjoy hawaii
thank you steven thank you for your love
thank you for supporting the film means
the world to me